hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys with Brett and Scott from how
ridiculous hey guys how you going you
emailed me in
2011 and then you finally got it
done all I had to do is wait for you to
have way more subscribers than us and I
thought Now's the
Time so you very kindly invited us to
Montana yes where you've procured a
bowling ball cannon we have it's been
many months in the making and I just
thought you know what what more Phantoms
is better more Phantoms is better we
used the bowling ball cannon a few years
ago on a TV show but we didn't really
have the speed or as many Phantoms so
we've got three today yeah yeah three
three Phantoms and uh picked up a nice
little
vintage Bing b bag here your luggage my
luggage the shoes in the sho got the
shoes yeah is that the idea good form
yeah that's what you do yeah okay I've
seen it in movies I've never seen that
before
and what are we going to be firing the
bowling ball at we've got some ballistic
gel sort of busts you know yeah here up
from ballistic dummy labs they got a bit
of a you know skull bone yeah Green
blood so it's less gruesome yeah that's
way better yeah that makes the
difference yeah so it saves the whole
thing suddenly fine why don't we go and
have a look at this out yeah BR how's it
looking from there well from my thorough
assessment I'd say it's a good chance
you need to close one ey oh it's like
you're playing snooker Lads I'll be
honest with you this seemed like it'd be
pretty funny on paper but now we're in
the moment and the Canon's pointed at it
and I framed up both Phantoms it's going
to be gruesome I can't help but feel
sorry for him what did you say about
this you said uh I just looked at it and
I was like that's right we do have
bones well you know what I mean like
it's just bizarre isn't look at it all
you know what I thought of when I saw
this is like the video you guys did many
years ago with the soccer ball to the
face mhm like this is you and the
bowling ball at like 350 mph theer I've
done a couple of times with the soccer B
gav asked me if I wanted to do this and
I was like I'm out how did you exactly
get hold of real human bones I mean I
can tell you as soon as I cut the camera
I'll tell you all about
it I'm actually a
clone okay so this is Dan 48 right we
replace Dan we don't replace his lab Cod
that's am Miss
got one angle th000 frames a second in
4k and a lovely tight on the TMX 7510 at
82,000 frames a second this one is going
to be horrendous is everyone ready for
what is potentially the most
questionable thing we've ever filmed
yes Dan yep send the ball that's right
I'll fire the cannon with this button on
a phone while you plunger the cameras
yeah ready y here we go 3 2 1 fire oh
gotot him
got him good
clean that is oh is that actually from
the thing what I don't understand before
we've gone to have a look is how the
shoulders are literally still there you
can see look at this come look at the
side profile here you can see the
profile if you look here of the ball all
the bones got ripped out of the head I'm
a trained
physiotherapist yeah what's this going
to need 6
months
which one's the clavicle I remember that
that's that one and they're good they're
fine clavicle is in perfect mix it
didn't get a bowling
ball see if the smoke obscure this one
oh oh
no so that it was censored mildly by the
smoke that's like a blurring by the Yeah
the next shot is not going to be the
next shot not in the way
no
oh my goodness fell apart it splashed
his
head it made it Splash
oh what have we done the ball hit him so
hard you can see a shock wave coming off
the impact that it's in about 150,000
pieces look at that that is Carnage the
B just carried on like it was nothing
and I love that the shoulder just stayed
there yeah how did that I think they may
have actually gone for a a bit of a peer
in the air wow there was more Carnage
than I expected they dropped an Olli
that was I think quite a good frame rate
for that you just see it just separating
out yeah it was you needed every one of
those 82,000 yeah and that that
ballistic you pushed it right it's quite
hard is it's solid did it actually
deflect the ball I don't think it was
deflected at all I don't think it cared
I just saw his the his face bones just
separated from each other well what is
quite disturbing to me is that there is
a moment where it's no longer a face
where it's just unrecognizable yeah and
it's pretty quick it's pretty early on
and it's just the face is shattered yeah
right let's line up five of them good
start yeah very very positive that is
all right this could be the back one and
then end like here yeah it looks like a
really morbid version of the Windows XP
background hang
[Music]
on let's go without the six ah okay
predictions well having sort of seen the
first one it's kind of cheating there's
going to be nothing
left all five are gone going down you'd
have to call five you'd have to call
five you'd be crazy not to yeah all
right well I'm Keen to see this right
ready ready 3 2 1
fire oh o wow that is nasty oh that was
hit hard eh do you reckon that hit the
table I'm slightly I was slightly
worried that I'd clipped the the the
wood of the table and that's why it I
think it's just the downward Force into
the mattresses because I've just seen
the wood and it seems to be okay but
it's just the fact that we've just hit
it so Square on that it smushed
everything downwards and the mattresses
have just boed up oh look at the green
like we had such a sophisticated table I
don't know how it didn't stand up I feel
like both of our channels embrace the
Jank in a real ni way I mean what is
YouTube but embracing the
so our new shirt right there so the over
the pressure from the bowling Bard
displacing all of the
heads
dising you both equally like
oo the 10 digits we we regularly
compliment each other when we say like a
cool word like where did you pull that
from okay and is probably not that high
of a standard but it felt good
obturation was good earlier obturation
was like
twice there a clavical oh there is they
whole and look the one and only coracoid
process if anyone wants to take things
to a new level's he's good is he so I
think the furthest piece I saw went over
by that little Mound you see the little
green bit in front of it that brown bit
scene this is like the face I
think oh God it looks like a Johnny it's
a Johnny it's a Johnny oh no that's
exactly what it is just load they just
load up Johnny and pering people no look
you could see if you if you filmed me
there on camera you could see my thought
process go that looks like a Johnny and
then I just went I watched it snap up
and then you just
paus oh God it looks like a
Johnny I found the vertebrae everyone
let's talk about that
The Slowdown was real though incredible
shot right in the
mouth I don't know if it's wrong of me
to say but like that was really
enjoyable a lot of Gump coming out of
the cannon now oh that was a good shot
it couldn't be more accurate that is
right in the old
schnoo oh what was that wow he actually
pushed the jaw it's like he ate it on
cave and now it's coming out the back of
the head it's out the back of the head
the next head took the previous spine to
the face all the vertebrae flying out
it's like a Mortal Kombat finisher oh
Collateral Damage
Big yeah like his his eye soet was
blowing away by now we get the grains so
he couldn't hold on for the bowling ball
he was already gone yeah he was already
done just to make sure we I think that's
the greatest video you've ever filmed
that was clean that was good
though look between the trampolines and
the heads it's been a good day it's can
you name a more you know iconic
Duo pretty pretty Grim pretty Grim very
hard to
unsee so apologies for that but uh I
think it was actually very interesting
footage yeah it was entertaining you
know I learned a little bit I couldn't
believe how it like shoved the the table
down yeah and flipped it up that was
crazy it just punches from all
directions it will goes through the face
but smash The Spine down through the
table yes but also the clavicle the
clavicles were we will never forget the
CL it's an
education what were they what was that
lingo you were using with your the
coracoid process that's the one that was
definitely involved that was involved Y
no there was there was a few of them
yeah that's from your other channel how
sensible yeah yeah I I talk about I just
talk about the names of Bones yeah it's
a great channel so what what video have
you got coming out around this time that
coincides with us it's a uh how many
trampolines how many trampol stops that
Cannon 1 2 5 20
who knows it's good it's good make sure
you watch that video is right here
thanks very much for being on our
Channel pleasure thanks for coming out
to America where we don't live to
collaborate with we'll have to pop down
to per soon maybe in uh 2034 yeah when
we've got 150 million
subscribers and we'll have
six thanks for
[Music]
watching